welcome to hannity and tonight the
gaslighting from democrats the mob in
the media is reaching record levels they
have
fake hysteria crocodile tears analogies
now to 911 pearl harbor and even the
holocaust complete with a special
performance from the cast of hamilton
it's a clown show on a spectacular level
and coming up we're going to bring you
much needed truth
into this conversation we will point out
all the rank hypocrisy the double
standards the lying the grandstanding
and who really is responsible for not
protecting the capital that the mob will
never talk about that the commission
will never investigate or committee will
never investigate former chief of staff
to the secretary of defense cash patel
he will be here and he will explain how
donald trump two days prior to january 6
last year wanted to call in 20 000
national guard troops before the january
6 date nancy pelosi and the d.c mayor
that spouser refused the guard in other
words this was all completely
preventable except democrats rejected
the protection uh we'll also get insight
from congressman jim jordan and
congressman jim banks they were booted
from the fake january 6 committee so
they could stack the deck 100 percent
against donald trump and we'll hear
firsthand from families of the victims
of the
574 violent riots from the summer of
2020
where is the committee investigating all
of those riots with dozens of dead
americans thousands of injured cops now
you remember that
at the beginning for example the riots
the fake news referred to as fiery
but mostly peaceful you know the
reporter would have a big fire behind
them but said it's mostly peaceful
all told thousands of police were
injured some very severely in the fiery
but peaceful protests as they said
dozens of americans dead there were over
600 arson attacks 97 police vehicles
were lit on fire a police precinct was
burned to the ground a federal
courthouse in portland was set ablaze
well pretty much every night for months
dozens of businesses were burned beyond
repair entire city blocks were taken
over by criminals in seattle in the
autonomous jazz chop summer of love zone
there were over 2 000 incidents of
looting and over 2 billion dollars in
property damage ryers writers even
attacked the white house with the
president and his family inside look at
this picture on your screen this was may
of 2020 violent demonstrators called
peaceful by democrats and the mob in the
media attempting to break through a
secret service barricade adjacent to the
white house grounds some even managed to
set historic st john's church on fire
the situation was so dangerous the
president and his family were forced to
flee to a secure bunker ultimately 60
secret service officers they sustained
injuries in the attack 11 were
transported to a local hospital but
according to democrats the media mob the
january 6 commission committee this
never happened where is the committee
investigating this take a look for
yourself should that be done by a
commission or the city council not a mob
in the middle of the night throwing it
into the harlem people will do what they
do violence across the whole country do
you just about the violence from antifa
that's happening in portland right now
that's right that's a myth that's being
spread only in washington d.c about
antifa in portland yes this is a mostly
protest uh it is not uh it is not
generally speaking unruly but fires have
been started there needs to be unrest in
the streets for as long as there is
unrest in our lives and unfortunately
there's plenty to go around
now then senator kamala harris she even
took it a step further she promoted the
bail fund for the violent rioters and in
june of 2020 in the middle of those
riots she told stephen colbert they're
not going to stop they shouldn't stop
we're not going to stop take a listen
i know that there are protests still
happening in major cities across the
united states i'm just not seeing the
reporting on it that i that i had that's
right for the first few weeks
um but they're not
they're not gonna stop and that's
they're not this is a movement i'm
telling you they're not gonna stop and
and everyone beware because they're not
gonna stop it is gonna they're not gonna
stop before election day in november and
they're not gonna stop after election
day and that should be everyone should
take note of that on both levels that
this isn't they're not going to let up
and they should not
beware take note they're not going to
stop we're not going to stop then
promoting a bail fund people involved
the burning down of a precinct and the
disaster that was minnesota at the time
well where when are we going to have the
committee investigate vice president
kamala harris while kamala harris
reveled in the violence president trump
he was attempting all through the summer
2020 to restore law and order all across
the country he was trying to use every
tool at his disposal including the
national guard and after a long summer
of large violent demonstrations
president trump knew how important it
was to always prepare for the worse
ahead of any massive demonstration you
always have bad actors unfortunately two
days before january 6 2020 we can now
report tonight completely and we will
have it backed up in a minute that
donald trump authorized up to 10
or 20 thousand national guard soldiers
to protect the capital the capitol
police chief also requested the national
guard not once not twice not three times
six separate times both nancy pelosi and
the mayor of washington d.c bowser they
needed to sign off on the president's
order and both rejected these requests
again and again
by doing so they left the capital
totally vulnerable and as we now know it
was breached within mere seconds cash
patel who will join us in a moment
provided us a document showing bowser's
rejection
and when will nancy pelosi and mayor
bowser be subpoenaed to testify before
this holier than now
sanctimonious january 6 committee that
has the likes of adam schiff the guy
that lied for three plus long years
about
election integrity issues that never
happened he lied over and over again
about trump russia collusion now likely
they'll never do it and ask yourself
this question if the true purpose of the
committee is to understand
what happened so that it can never
happen again how can you possibly ignore
the issue of rejecting the national
guard that the president called up the
only reason i can think of is the compa
committee is playing partisan politics
and it has a predetermined outcome all
they want to do is bludgeon and blame
trump again everybody on the committee
voted to impeach trump post presidential
uh his post-presidential service the
books are cooked that's why congressman
jim jordan and congressman jim banks
were barred from the committee we'll
hear from them tonight keep in mind
every single member of the january six
committee as i said seven democrats and
two republicans they all voted to
impeach donald trump and over the
weekend one of those committee members
liz chaney said her goal was to block
president trump from ever getting near
the white house again earlier today in a
highly divisive speech joe biden echoed
cheney's fever dreams and accused donald
trump of doing nothing to protect the
capital we now know that's false take a
look
we didn't see a former president
who had just rallied the mob to attack
sitting in the private dining room off
the oval office in the white house
watching it all on television
and doing nothing
for hours
as police were assaulted
lives at risk
the nation's capital under siege
rally to attack uh many of you will now
peacefully and patriotically march to
the capitol so your voices can be heard
uh calling up the national guard uh is
that rallying an attack now had pelosi
and bowser actually listen to donald
trump knowing that we had
574 riots over the summer previously
knowing there was a big march planned
for that day knowing that it's sadly
pretty predictable when you have a large
crowd that there will always be bad
actors knowing tensions were high in the
country post the 2020 election all of
this could have been prevented donald
trump authorized the national guard all
while democrats blocked his efforts to
secure the capital and don't forget
trump said again many of you will now
peacefully patriotically march to the
capitol so your voices may be heard but
of course those words don't matter do
they to democrats that have an agenda
the democratic party they never let
truth and facts get in the way of a good
narrative look at for example over msdnc
they actually had a historian
comparing january 6th
to the holocaust
take a look
we have film footage of what happened on
january 6th we have proof
dwight eisenhower during world war ii
made sure all the holocaust camps were
filmed so we've got the film footage my
worry is what do we call this and make
sure we we honor this day this dark
stained day every year so we've got to
keep saying january 6th i think it is
like december 7th pearl harbor it is
like the 9 11
tragedy
now today vice president kamala harris
also made a pretty horrible comparison
herself by the way this is the person
that tweeted out oh support the bail
fund for the people involved with the
peaceful protesting riots same person uh
that said they're not gonna stop they
shouldn't stop we're not gonna stop take
a look
certain dates echo throughout history
including dates
that instantly
remind all who have lived through them
where they were
and what they were doing
when our democracy came under assault
dates that occupy
not only a place on our calendars
but a place in our collective memory
december 7 1941
september 11
2001
and january 6
2021.
now 2403 americans died at pearl harbor
i know pretty well my father served in
the pacific for four years and nearly 3
000 were murdered on 9 11 2001. dozens
of americans were killed in the summer
riots of 2020 that kamala harris cheered
on
so please spare us the low class
theatrics kamala because you know what
you're looking pretty stupid right now
take a look
my thoughts immediately turned
not only to my colleagues
but to my staff
who had been forced to seek refuge in
our office
converting filing cabinets
into barricades this is a movement i'm
telling you they're not going to stop
the lawlessness
the violence
the chaos
and and everyone beware because they're
not gonna stop it is gonna they're not
gonna stop before election day in
november and they're not gonna stop
after election day the violent assault
that took place here the very fact of
how close we came
to an election
overturned
that
reflects the fragility of democracy
and that should be everyone should take
note of that on both levels that this
isn't they're not going to let up and
they should not
let me be clear also tonight unlike
kamala harris and most of the democrats
we have been extraordinarily consistent
we do we do not on this program let
politics determine whether one riot's a
good one or a bad one there's no such
thing in real time on my radio show this
is from january 6 2021 as the events of
that day were unfolding this is what i
was saying
i've seen one or two videos of some
vandalism uh every good decent honorable
american would condemn all violence and
urge any protesters that want to go down
that road you know i see a lot of older
people moms and dads and and families
and stuff but you there's always going
to be the agitators in some of these
groups the people that seem to always
want to praise peaceful protesters are
the media and the democratic party
because they went to great lengths
to defend and even instances where there
was violence they didn't condemn the
violence i condemn anybody involved in
any incident involved in violence it's
that simple we got to protect everybody
and i don't care whether you agree with
somebody who disagree protect our police
you got to protect kids that are at this
rally and older people that are at this
rally
and i went on to say the capital and our
elected officials and here's how we
covered it the night of january six
right here on this show
those who truly support president trump
those that believe they are part of the
conservative movement in this country
you do not we do not support those that
commit acts of violence they people we
don't believe should be vandalizing our
nation's capital attacking the brave men
and women that keep us safe in law
enforcement and all of today's
perpetrators must be arrested and
prosecuted to the full extent of the law
but every good and decent american we
know will and must condemn what happened
at the capitol and moving forward
we have got to do a dramatically better
job protecting the innocent men and
women who work there we've got to
protect our law enforcement officers
we've got to protect every single
elected member of the congress and
senate this is not politics they deserve
to be protected
now that's right the media mob has been
lying about me all week we've been
incredibly consistent all throughout
they're the hypocrites they had a very
different standard in the summer of 2020
we've been honest about it uh january 6
the rights of summer of 2020. democrats
the medium mob nope they haven't been
consistent they want you to believe that
january 6 was an insurrection they want
trump locked up
and barred from ever running again they
want to purge him from the republican
party which is what committee members
now want why are they ignoring trump's
call for the national guard two days
prior why won't they call as a witness
or subpoena nancy pelosi of mayor bowser
look at the cb s poll that came out
buried by the news organization or
so-called news organization a vast
majority of americans believe january 6
was a protest that went too far however
according to the political class this
was a violent insurrection caused by
donald trump who called for peaceful
protests carried out by a group of
people who refused to accept the results
of 2020. we've been hearing all day that
anyone that ever cast out on election
results is a monster democrats uh
they've never done the same you might
remember the dirty dossier bought and
paid for by hillary clinton that accused
donald trump of being a russian asset
and how russia helped him win the
election in 2016. you might remember the
years and years of claims that president
trump's election was illegitimate biden
and harris they themselves echoed this
dangerous lie they accused donald trump
of cheating with putin's help all of
this has now been debunked completely
and they said it over and over again and
then adam shifts you know another shift
show he sits on the committee when he
led the effort led the lying the
conspiracy theories the hoax and we
never talk about that take a look
i think he's an illegitimate president
that didn't really win so how do you you
know fight against that in 2020 you are
absolutely right the president
is an illegitimate racist occupying the
white house who has defined himself over
and over again i believe he knows he's
an illegitimate president he knows he
knows that there were a
bunch of different reasons why the
election turned out the way it did but
the russian
uh uh uh
weighing in on the election the russian
attempt to have the election and frankly
the fbi is weighing in on the election i
think make the make makes his election
illegitimate illegitimate and my biggest
fear is that he's going to do it again
with the help of vlad his best pal
and we're going to be stuck for six more
years this guy and that is terrifying
it's terrifying would you be my vice
president from canada
folks look i absolutely agree
that was a three plus year lie by
democrats yes questioning the legitimacy
of the 2016 election the media they lied
right along with them the worst offender
in spreading the lie the congenital liar
adam schiff and he's on the january 6
committee uh it doesn't get any more
sick or ironic than that and then
there's stacey abrams herself god bless
her she still thinks she's the rightful
governor of georgia take a look
this is not a speech of concession
because concession means to acknowledge
an action is right true or proper
as a woman of conscience and faith i
cannot concede that but will i say that
this election was not tainted was not a
disinvestment and a disenfranchisement
of thousands of voters i will not say
that do you think the vote was stolen
from you the election was stolen from me
i think the election was stolen from the
people of georgia
and she's loved by all the democrats
they all like stacey abrams the 2016
election that's uh we we won't talk
about that democrats have challenged
every single election loss in modern
american history here's a headline from
the new york magazine yes bush v gore
did steal the election another quote al
gore won florida 2000 and another we
really did inaugurate the wrong guy now
the same media mob wants you to believe
that if you question an election result
that's treason liz cheney has now
partnered with the very people that
thought her vice president father was
not legitimately elected and was on top
of that a crook a war criminal a liar
and a murderer now democrats want to
distract from the country you know
biden's failures of president and
exploit the one riot last year to end
the filibuster and pass their radical
election reform and it's not really
election reform it's an unconstitutional
ploy to ban voter id all across the
country and ban partisan observers from
watching the vote count ban chain of
custody mechanisms for ballots ban
updates for voter rolls and stop and
some democrats even want illegal
immigrants to have the right to vote in
other words they want it to be easier to
harvest ballots and in some cases get
illegal immigrants to vote to the polls
and as you know democrats never let a
good crisis go to waste so make no
mistake january 6 is not the somber day
for them that they're acting like sadly
they are exploiting this as a political
opportunity otherwise nancy pelosi mayor
bowser would be called in and they would
rightly be questioned why did they not
go along with donald trump's call for
the national guard they're even
celebrating with a special musical
performance we won't play it now from
the cast of hamilton